It may not seem like it, but teasing done
with affection and skill is a profound human
accomplishment. There’s nasty teasing, of
course – in which we pick away at a sore
spot in someone’s life. But here we’re talking
of the affectionate version, something
generous and loving – which feels good to
be on the receiving end of.
It may be lovely to be teased when, for example,
you’re a teenager and in a grumpy, sullen
mood, and your kindly dad nicknames you Hamlet,
Shakespeare’s Danish prince of gloom. Or
when you’re 45 and pretty serious in business
and your old university friends come around
and call you by that name they made up for
you aged 19, the night you failed dismally
trying to pick up a German girl who was in
town.
All of us get a bit unbalanced in one way
or another: too serious, too gloomy, too jokey.
And so we all benefit from being tugged back
towards a healthier mean. The good-teaser
latches onto and responds to our distinctive
imbalances and gets compassionately constructive
about trying to change us: not by delivering
a stern lesson, but by helping us to notice
our excesses and laugh at them. We sense the
teaser trying to give us a useful little shove
in a good (and secretly welcome) direction
and therefore know that, at its affectionate
best, teasing is at once sweet and constructive.
The English literary critic Cyril Connolly
once famously said: Imprisoned in every fat
man a thin man is wildly signalling to be
let out.
It’s a general idea with multiple variants:
inside the fussy, over formal individual there’s
a more relaxed person looking for an opening;
there’s an ambitious, eager self quietly
despairing within the lazy man; the gloomy,
disenchanted cynic harbours a more cheery,
sunny sub-self in need of more recognition.
The teasing remark speaks over the head of ones dominant personality to the subordinated side
of the self, whom it helps to release and
relax. There’s a moment in The Line of Beauty
– a novel by Alan Hollinghurst, set in the
1980s – in which Nick, the charming young
central character, is invited to a grand party
and meets the British Prime minister, Margaret
Thatcher. Everyone is slightly terrified of
her, but Nick warmly and teasingly suggests
she might like to dance to a pop song. The
other guests are horrified – she’s meant
to be obsessed by stringent economic reform
and hard-nosed politics – but after a brief
inner struggle, she replies with a smile:
‘You know, I’d like that very much.’
(Perhaps if, in reality, there had been more
people to tease her, the pop-loving, dancing
side of Mrs Thatcher might have played a greater
role in national affairs – and history would
have been different).
When we enjoy being warmly teased, it’s
because the teasing remark emerges from a
genuine insight into who we are. This person
has studied us and put their finger on a struggle
that’s going on in us; they’ve taken the
part of a nice – but currently under-supported
– side of who we are. It’s pleasing because
normally others don’t see much past the
front we put on for the world. Typically,
the world just thinks we are gloomy, or stern,
or intellectual, or obsessed by fashion. The
teaser does us the favour of recognising that
the dominant front isn’t telling the whole
story; they’re kind enough and perceptive
enough to see past the surface. Perhaps the
most instructive question we can ask – the
one that teaches us most about the value of
affectionate teasing – is simply: what do
I need to be teased about? .